for more we turn to philip bump national
correspondent for the Washington Post
Philip good morning good morning we
could go in so many different directions
here but let me start with the health
care bill because Mitch McConnell wanted
to have something before the July 4th
break right there's obviously not a bill
together yet but where the things stand
at this point so it's a good question so
the Senate Republicans were pushing on
this bill hoping to get it done this
week in part because they didn't want to
have to take a recess go back to their
districts and hear from all the people
who are unhappy about this bill it's a
very unpopular belt surprisingly
unpopular bill only you know most
polling shows about one in five people
approve of it so where it stands right
now is Mitch McConnell was trying to
resolve the differences between the
moderate wing of his party and the
conservative wing of his party and it's
not clear he's having much success
who is more ascendant in terms of this
power struggle though it is McConnell
trying to cater to the moderates the the
susan collins of the world the dean
Heller's of the world or is he being
pushed more towards catering to the
conservatives like Rand Paul and Ted
Cruz well I think the general thinking
is that the Conservatives will
eventually come on board with a bill
that ends up overhauling Obamacare
because Obamacare is very unpopular
whereas the moderates have a very valid
argument which is that people are upset
about the idea of these cuts to Medicaid
in particular and of the possibility of
premiums increasing over the long term
so I my guess is that it's probably the
moderates who are the ones that are
going to be the holdouts but of course
there are fewer of them which makes
McConnell's job a little easier
in the middle of all this we have the
latest Twitter storm of course where
does that leave the president's agenda
how does that affect the President's
agenda right so it's been fascinating
because this this month that White House
communications team said each week we're
gonna focus on something we're focus on
the infrastructure or energy or
technology and if you actually look at
what Donald Trump Donald Trump I said oh
my Twitter account is my way of talking
to the people you know 90% of the time
literally 90% of the time he was
tweeting about random other things the
rush Investigation Joe and mica on MSNBC
so the problem is that the White House
communications team for all of their
effort towards establishing here's what
we're gonna talk about the president
doesn't want to talk about he wants talk
about what he wants to talk about and
that's a challenge for my communications
what is that done to his relationship
with Congress and Congress is
effectively tasked with carrying out his
agenda have relations frayed do these
tweets the accumulation of
all of these tweets do they fray
relations even further well one has to
assume that people on Capitol Hill get
tired of being asked how do you feel
about the president's tweet about X
right I mean obviously there's some
frustration I think Speaker Paul Ryan
has sort of mastered this art of saying
well I don't really want to focus on
that but if you look at what happened on
Friday with this this sudden tweet about
let's repeal first and then replace Ben
Sasse was very smart in that he put out
this letter saying let's do this but
then he went on Fox & Friends on Friday
morning and said the same thing and
within 20 minutes Donald Trump had
picked up that mantle so Congress is
getting smart about how they get Donald
Trump to do what they want but that
doesn't really help congressional
leaders actually pass legislation in 20
to any extent do you think the president
is trying to distract attention from
other things not really I mean it
certainly seems there's a lot of
evidence at hand that suggests that
Donald Trump simply tweets about
whatever is on his mind that there isn't
some grand calculus behind it and I
think the fact that he responds for
example to television within a matter of
minutes indicates that that's what he's
doing and and still the Russia
investigation continues what is the
latest on the House Intelligence probe
so the House Intelligence Committee next
month we'll hear from Susan Rice the
former national security adviser for
Barack Obama which will probably be
something that Donald Trump in his
allies will celebrate because she has
sort of been positioned as the person
who is responsible for this whole
investigation into Donald Trump's
campaign at the same time the committee
will also hear in a closed-door session
from Michael Caputo who worked on the
campaign the news there probably will be
less good for the administration
meanwhile in this coming week the
president will meet for the first time
with Vladimir Putin right what do we
expect from that well it'll be
interesting to see what actually emerges
obviously the timing for it is not good
for the president because of all these
questions that surround him around his
relationship with Russia and this
campaigns relationship with Russia we
can anticipate they'll probably talk
about Syria where tensions have raised
because of military actions but we can
also just even probably won't bring up
last time Barack Obama and Vladimir
Putin met Barack Obama talked to Putin
about pay this meddling in the election
you've got to cut that out the odds are
good that probably won't come up this
time all right feel a bump thank you
very much for being with us